we have joined the police patrol in the
townships wherever we go everyone runs
away because they know they shouldn't be
on the streets and they are afraid the
officers on duty seem anxious they admit
they can hardly keep these huge areas
under control the enforcement of the
lockdown is anything but systematic it
appears random this man couldn't get
away fast enough he's been fined for
1,500 runs about 80 euros the man says
that during the arrest he was kicked and
beaten by the police behind the house we
couldn't verify this from our position a
few blocks away we meet a young woman
who doesn't want to show her face she's
afraid she'll be recognized but she does
want to show what the police did to her
just for being on the street
she says several officers stomped into
her house and detector with sticks and
whips and all this in front of her
daughter
so anyway because I was in pain if
they're not helping us I mean can we
trust the police defends their harsh
action in the townships if they don't
listen then unfortunately those things
happened I'm not saying it's right and
in some communities that's all the
members of the public understand they
need to see those things unfortunately
before they adhere to instructions yes
they need to see that this is serious
and the police are not just telling you
to go in the house because you know it's
a volatile instruction it's difficult
for many South Africans to observe the
lockdown despite all the warnings
the call for physical distancing goes
unheeded in these long lines at the
supermarkets many day laborers simply
can't afford to stay home for long
periods this is the reality for millions
of South Africans and although the
lockdown rules of the three-week
lockdown yeah extremely strict many
people are simply not able to comply
police fear the tension and the
townships were worsen the longer the
lockdown stays in effect nobody knows
the invisible Bogota like this man for
15 years Orlando Beltran has been
looking after the city's homeless he
knows where they meet where they sleep
and where they get their drugs with his
NGO el banco de el Bronx the Bronx
banquet he provides the destitute with
food clothes and a shoulder to lean on
but the most important part of today's
delivery are these face masks face masks
can save many lives the drugs they smoke
damage the muscles in their mouths so
it's hard for them to control their
saliva and they may accidentally spit on
each other without realizing the corona
virus could wreak havoc among Bogota
homeless population but it's not only
the limited access to clean water soap
and medical attention that increases
their vulnerability misinformation is
Orlando's biggest enemy in times of the
pandemic I heard 20 million people have
died in Spain I think the mafia is
behind it
they conjure up the virus and then they
find a cure it's all about money here in
the streets we have stronger immune
systems
that's better than their cure Orlando's
help is needed now more than ever ever
since Colombia went into lockdown it has
become hard for the homeless to get
money begging or collecting metal and
rubbish makes little
when the only people left on the street
are those with nowhere to go
with police in charge of enforcing the
quarantine this young man tells us he's
often violently chased off the streets
tell us to leave but if we don't they
tase us and beat us I do what I can to
avoid that I try to collect some money
and find a place to sleep those who can
afford it escaped police brutality in
these temporary housing facilities but
sharing a windowless room with dozens of
people who roam the streets of Bogota
during the day may well increase their
risk of contracting the virus under
these conditions
Orlando's masks may seem like a band-aid
on a bullet wound but it's all these
people have and even the skeptics wear
their masks like shields protecting them
from an invisible menace the end of the
day is bittersweet for Orlando to leave
but I'm happy because we gave them hope
the hope of us coming back and bringing
along the humanitarian aid for the
homeless he knows it's a stretch but
it's this hope that has kept him going
for the past 15 years that and the
smiles on the faces of those he has
helped smiles he may not be able to see
under the new masks but he still knows
they're there
[Music]